Fox News has now confirmed that the
suspect in the main mass shooting Robert
card has been found dead we're going to
have a lot more on this later in the
show but before we get back to it let me
give you a few of the details they're a
little sketchy at this time all 18
victims have now been identified by
authorities the shelter and place order
as everyone knows has been lifted um
among them was a married couple in their
70s a father and his 14-year-old son for
adults associated with the main
Educational Center for the deaf a gun
Note cell phone belonging to the suspect
found earlier today by the police divers
sonar equipment search the river near
where the suspect's uh car was found
abandoned Wednesday night near where
apparently he had a boat and a press
conference now will be held um I guess
sometime early tomorrow morning and
going forward anyway police uh to their
credit working through the many many
hundreds of tips from people around them
but let me repeat the suspect in this
main shooting has now been confirmed as
dead um we'll have more details to
follow throughout the night hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else